[Music]
that song bad let's talk about Justice
League and the future of Beck's lake
that's Ben Affleck as Batman bat flick
you put it together
Oh Justice League Justice League Justice
League Justice League there's a lot on
the internet surrounding Justice League
people getting bad reviews are getting
hated on people can giving good reviews
we're getting hated on we're not doing
any of that today if you're here for a
hot take I'm not gonna give it what I'm
gonna do is give you some what does what
am I doing with Wonder Woman what I am
gonna do is give you some hot theories
strap on your tinfoil hat and have a
seat
but if you are wondering my thoughts I'm
gonna give it to you anyway I like
Justice League I thought it was a lot of
fun had a lot of fun watching it in the
theater I'm not comparing it to any
other movies it's just it's straight-up
fun III see the problems but it's fun
the flash aka
Ezra Miller steals the show every line
out of his mouth is pure gold I was
afraid that they were gonna use up all
of his lines in the trailer and it
started to seem that way at first but
then no no lots of lots and lots of
banked content thank God I was also
pleasantly surprised with cyborg he kind
of seemed like a bit of a bore bit of a
bore in the trailer but then he's got
these like wonderful pure moments where
I'm like right Fisher I'm on board with
your standalone movie give it to me and
then there's Aquaman who's in the
trailer going like yeah boy my man and
you're kind of like oh god this is gonna
be such a bro what's happening and then
you watch the movie and you're like
Aquaman is a bro and I like it works a
lot Jason Momoa is there with his
beautiful flawless mane of hair that's
better than mine I go to my hair stylist
I'm like give me this just like a bat I
dig it but no it's great I love it it
works so much and I can't say much about
the other characters without spoiling
their mustaches you know what I'm saying
but before we move on to Batman I do
want to say one thing that I loved so
much about the movie is
the credits and I know that sounds crazy
but as far as post-credit scenes go I am
not kidding you this is one of the best
that I have ever seen in a superhero
movie if not the best that I've seen in
a superhero movie I have goosebumps all
right now it's time to talk about Ben
Affleck aka Batman and his future in the
franchise the DC EU and I am gonna get
into some plot points about Batman's
behavior Bruce Wayne's behavior in the
movie so if you don't want to hear any
of that I would come back after you
watch Justice League I'm not gonna give
too much away but just a little bit
about how he behaves in the movie so
let's start with some behind the scenes
backstory we're going to the summer of
2017 y'all so over the summer there was
a report that Ben Affleck wanted out of
the DC EU he didn't want to be a part of
it anymore and that he might not even be
doing the Batman especially because he
was originally scheduled to direct the
Batman and then stepped aside and then
Matt Reeves stepped in to direct the
movie then during San Diego comic-con
during the panel Ben Affleck addressed
all of this and he was like cursing a
lot he's like listen I am so lucky to be
in this role I would crawl on the ground
and like kiss Matt Reeves feet I love
this franchise and I loved this role and
I loved being a part of it but hold on a
second let's take this from like a PR
perspective to me this confirms that Ben
Affleck is probably going to do the
Batman but it doesn't really confirm
that he still doesn't want to not
continue the role after that so let's
get into Justice League in Justice
League Bruce Wayne aka Batman has this
behavior of like I'm Way too old for
this I'm so old I can't keep up with you
guys that's kind of his behavior
throughout the whole movie he's just
kind of having trouble like keeping up
with the rest of the team and then he
keeps saying it out loud and it almost
seems like they dressed him to look
older than the rest of the team even
though he's not Wonder Woman it's like
way older than him but you know
physically he's a human being so it felt
like to me that they're starting to tee
up the fact that Batman
may no longer be physically able to
watch over Gotham but Gotham needs a
hero because Gotham is a horrible place
to live why do people live in Gotham
there's so much crime there is so much
crime there's so much crime there's so
much crime
so Bruce Wayne is not going to leave
Gotham unattended he needs to pass the
reins on to somebody else but going back
behind the scenes we know two things are
happening in the future the one there is
a Batgirl movie coming directed by Joss
Whedon which I assume is going to be the
Barbara Gordon version of Batgirl
aka Jim Gordon JK Simmons daughter we
haven't heard much about that movie
other than the fact that it's happening
they announced it in the slate at Comic
Con no casting news so we got to do a
little fan casting right now I'm onboard
with Olivia Cook who was in me and Earl
and the dying girl she's great in it
I've heard Carly off camera here said
Emma Roberts and I like Emma Roberts
have you seen scream 4 don't hate scream
4 I love scream 4 so we know Batgirl is
happening and that could be a way for
Bruce Wayne to pass on the reins tobacco
should watch over Gotham or or or or we
know that there is a live action
Nightwing movie happening Nightwing
Robin Dick Grayson becomes Nightwing
yeah Chris McKay is directing that movie
he's said on Twitter that it's kind of
way off and they haven't done casting
yet but let me put this into your brain
space and let's see let's see how you
like it
my coworker Meredith Kyle said this to
me the other day and I can't think about
anything else
Dev Patel as Nightwing I know I know so
I put this out on Twitter and then
apparently everybody was like we've been
saying this for years Ashley get on
board and then somebody sent me a fan
art of Dev Patel as Nightwing and it is
glorious it's the most beautiful thing
I've ever seen
it's my iPhone Bagram
literally my iphone background what do
you guys think thank you for being on
this ride is the DCE you setting up
Batman's exit I think so and if so who
do you think should take the reins will
be Batgirl will be Nightwing will it be
both of them like will they team up and
I'm like a whole thing they'll be great
and also who are your fan castings for
Batgirl and Nightwing and if it's not
done Patel for Nightwing don't at me but
if you have some ideas for Batgirl I
will accept those okay I'm taking I'll
consider now I've got to go because I've
got to go finish Star Wars Battlefront 2
because I just started playing it last
night and I keep dying because I keep
flying into Death Star debris on my TIE
fighter but if I get that done soon I'm
gonna do a video on that so let me know
if you want to see that or what you want
to see next
like comment subscribe you can always
tweet me I'm available around the clock
I tweet too much alright I'll see you
guys next time